um Fisher random coming up chess960 I
can hear it already why are the pieces
messed up there might be some
explanations needed and many of the
viewers on Twitch might be sick of
answering that same question I'm sure it
happens a lot but uh what can you do
yes this is Fisher random this is
chess960 look it up you will know more
about it if you do 960 arrangements for
this back row Jess will not go extinct
any time fast
there is always Fisher random to rely
upon if that uh
if it ever goes in that direction throw
out all the opening books most of them
still general principles to be taking
into account and my opponent is taking
one of those into account right now with
that first move controlling a central
square with one of these four pawns now
what is unprotected nothing okay so it's
my first thing it's my first thing to be
looking out for now I think I might want
to play the copycat game once again
because I I see I see that this is just
I mean it's a good move and my rook
wants to be able to play and their
Bishop wants to be able to see and both
of them are seeing here's another thing
bishops these guys do not need to move
in order to be functioning now this guy
needs to move before I could Castle
kingside if I really wanted to do that I
need to clear out these four pieces it
seems like well actually touching on the
subject of where to castle with the King
what I really want to keep my King
around on this side of the board with
these two bishops breathing down his
neck mm-hmm that's a bit scary
once again my night out and think about
that a little bit later usually I like
to play something like c5 the knight
here but I'm not really too happy about
something like
now that's a bit scary so I guess they
could damage my structure here
but they're having to give up the light
square bishop if that's gonna happen
I need my queen outta my Bishop out if I
really want to castle this pot is gonna
need to move here soon but I'm looking
into doing some other things first
there might be this a formal plate or
even D 3 and E 4 okay just eat four
right away well here's the here's the
plan here here here my thoughts my
thoughts are if I don't take this pond
this pond is gonna give my knight a
beating and a half he's gonna scare my
knight so I don't want to give that pond
the option to push my pieces around no
I'll stop you right in your tracks
don't you dare push my pieces around now
what plan up do I really think there's
gonna be a better spot for this guy this
guy really he would really like to play
the game wouldn't he let's go Bishop see
the board g6 it's already feeling keto a
fiend kettled Bishop right from the
initial position might as well consider
like that if I play d6 I'm really
weakening this Square and I want to be
extra cautious about weakening any
squares on this I say d6 I messed the
squares up I think more than I get them
right but anyhow if I play here I'm
weakening east six and that's that
should have your concern if you're gonna
if you're gonna do that as black this is
a half-open file for white you can very
easily see some pieces pivoting on that
square if I'd ever do this move so what
am I getting at I'm getting at
I'm getting out the idea of just don't
do that move so what about this what
about that guy well I might need to end
up doing that but maybe I take here
first yeah let's take care bringing that
Bishop out but so what I'm I was a bit
concerned about pieces getting to this
square they could get there and they
might be needing to do this it might be
so good an idea to be pivoting about on
the c5 square that I'll need to be
covering it and weakening this a little
bit it's like it's almost like a reverse
I was ready to say Hedgehog but no I
don't know about that but it's like a
small pawn Center for sure small Ponson
and I think I'm needing to do something
like this
or am i I'm gonna go oh I have an idea
Hana this is guarded front up Queen here
and then I'm ready to queenside castle I
was anticipating eventually a queen
coming over here putting pressure on my
knight I need to go quicker I could
clean side castle I'm in a spot to do
that I could still consider King site
castling but that seems a bit scary with
this Bishop functioning in both
directions in fact this is the I think
the most valuable piece for white right
now I think it's really well positioned
hitting at both lengths of the board if
I play King's side you can anticipate a
h4 h5 peeling open the H file cracking
down on this structure I think queenside
castle is my safest bet I can also
excuse me it's had a flashback of a bad
Nature Valley experience right there
from the last stream I could consider
pinpointing this pun and what a decision
we have here now to give up the light
square Bishop I don't think that that is
a good idea
Queen recapture pun I am actually
considering pawn because of this rip to
the B file pinpointing this
do I like it enough to do it I don't I'm
more concerned about what Oh what is
this night up to what is up this night
sleeve here I can't be right I think my
opponent is seeing that they could get
this pond when really they can't that's
my guess cuz now I'm hitting the night
in the pond and I'm ready to play a five
and kick him away queenside castles
available less than a minute my opponent
using only half their time this night
you need to go somewhere else get out of
there
whoa whoa okay well let me just do this
I'm not quite sure what I did want to do
it my king let's get some space I might
want to do a rook up and over and my
opponent is flying let's let's go here
it seems like a nice cozy square light
square she can't be kicked away so
easily I'm still not sure where I want
to go with my king I want to keep him
right there rook up and over
possibilities I'm keeping available I
think my Queen position might be so good
Queen e2 is maybe being thought of right
now
Queen trade if that's the case then I'll
be wanting to probably place my king on
d7 there's no need to castle keep him in
the center get my Brooks connected just
by making it King move I've pressure on
the rook possibilities for Queen to a2
if the knight moves maybe even ideas of
b5 be for going right after the king I
don't I'm not seeing any successful pawn
break okay and that's exactly what
happened so let me follow up with what I
said I would King to d7 know that the
Queen's are off and I think b5 well
can't be played so easily so I'm gonna
do this and then this and then try and
get this move in
let's go I have this covered a little
wall right here in front of my king the
night plays here and is looking to come
here I could play this to box him out my
LightSquared Bishop would like to do
something more than stare at his own
pond 32 seconds let's stop that night
from getting excited about things like
g5 stuff in other words let's go Bishop
and I'd for a fraction of a second I
considered Bishop f6 there let's not
drop pieces okay Bishop f6 don't do that
what what should I be doing yeah well my
light-square bishop has seen better days
definitely has seen better days okay
here's the plan my bishop is gonna want
to play on d7 oh you know my point was
being sneaky they're ready for this
night check move and then the rooks are
gonna give me a beating or at least I
think that was their plan so okay let's
do this I have a good outpost here and
watching over this square I want to be
cautious about giving up the Dark Star
bishops and allowing the night to get to
f6 22 seconds down to the wire now where
are the breaking points there's a
breaking point pawns err exchanged them
up upon No let's come all the way back
here I did consider this so I could
double next but that's gonna allow for
the pawn push but maybe it wouldn't
because that's a legal move I should
have played here I should have played
here yeah I didn't have to go here why
not go here no time left I'm actually
considering taking with the rug but
there's no time just move well in this
pond my LightSquared bishop let's come
over here it's more fun over here oh
wait they could actually take that pawn
they have enough support I want to keep
something on the board here I don't want
to trade too much time situation time
time where are we at get the bishop or
the pond no time
oh man tight game as soon as those
Queens came off it's tough for me to do
something you had a space advantage I
wasn't seeing a successful pawn break
yes my opponents saying another time
burner that's true it seems to end up in
that sort of situation you say thanks
for another you are welcome good game
let's see here now what about what about
d3 and d4 look into that that's another
possibility the pawn push immediately in
the center I think is a good one
still the knight move yeah I wasn't
actually thinking about it during the
game but I and I usually do don't
obstruct that center pond how about this
how about you take the knight and I'll
probably recapture with the bishop and
when I do you could play who actually
doesn't matter if I do or I don't
capture with the bishop if I capture the
bishop or pawn it doesn't matter I
believe you could play e5 that's what
I'm trying to say and I'm fumbling as
I'm trying to say it so play E or not me
fine
geez d4 after I after you take here how
about you follow up with d4 and then you
could look into Knight f3 and then e 5 I
think that's a wonderful outpost for the
night if you're having pawns on d4 and
f4 the square that should be crying out
to you is the e5 square get him there
there's a slight improvement getting
your your D Wow
getting your deep uninvolved a little
bit earlier I think is a good thing
don't obstruct your central pawns think
twice before you do that so and giving
up the light square bishop you can't do
that I don't know what's being
accomplished with that so I would that's
another thing that
I'm questioning I think it's the right
idea to get rid of my queen she is a
better place than I think your queen
could ever be in such a structure so get
rid of it and keep pressure on my pawns
you're trying to get active with your
knight I'm trying to make sure he
doesn't have a great support point I
think at the end of this well I'm up I'm
up upon right here I know I'm off two
pawns but this is a blunder I shouldn't
have done that you know you get at least
a pawn back and right here just a final
note welcome this sort of exchange don't
throw yourself into a pin in fact if I
knew you're going to be capturing with
your Bishop right here I should be
looking into just Bishop here which is
winning actually it's losing because
you're threatening Bishop here with the
check if my King was on a light square
would be losing okay so anyhow you have
a trick up your sleeve there and I
defend against that so anyhow how about
this I mean another thing to consider is
just here get to get the rooks off and
it's uh
I guess it's still a little bit tricky
with the possibility for either one of
these to maybe be a passed pawn on the
flanks but I think trading down into
just a more simplified opposite color of
Bishop ending is going to give you a
greater possibility to hold a draw okay
I think I said that right